not even fooling I love rats patreon
sponsored review time last couple of
these were films that I had not seen
before I got the the request and the
Commission effectively to to review them
for the channel this one I have and it's
been one that I part of me wants to say
like I've been meaning to talk about it
for a long time and that's kind of true
but kind of not like it's been on my
list of stuff to eventually do an
animation junkie on since I started
doing animation junkie but so has about
50 other things which I haven't gotten
to either so it was never a high on the
priority so it's kind of nice to have a
reason to bump it up and and actually
talk about it so let's discuss the
secret of NIMH and I'll sort of use this
as a little bit of a divergence to talk
about Don Bluth specifically as an
animation director because I find him
fascinating his movies haven't always
been great but they've always had a
really unique visual flavor to them they
have this especially with some of these
stories this really amazing mix of
frankly very frightening imagery yet
everything has a roundness to what kind
of a bounciness to it and yet it's
really hard to describe his animation
style as excessively cartoonish it's
really pretty unique at least to my eye
it is and secret of NIMH one was the
first film that he directed on his own
he had worked with Disney for a while
but like many sort of up-and-coming
hungry young young ish animators of the
late 70s early 80s he got disillusioned
there pretty quickly because Disney at
the time he was there was in a weird
place because they mo Disney himself
Walt Disney was no longer around but a
fair number of the old guard was still
there and trying to make the new guys do
it the way they did it when the new guys
kind of wanted to do something new and
there was a lot of clashing of
what the people who've been there
forever wanted to have happen what the
people who were coming in and we're
going to ultimately revitalize the thing
wanted to be doing so Dom Bluth and his
frustration left started making his own
movie starting with this one now this is
based off a book which I haven't read
this really is Don Bluth in a nutshell
it is mysterious it is visually gorgeous
it is creepy he does moody and
atmospheric animation so phenomenally
which honestly can be really hard to
find in 2d you get it in 3d a bit more
these days I feel because you know with
the with the way that you can do
lighting effects and things like fog or
whatever in 3d animation especially at
this point in time 2d animation you've
really gotta put so much work into
trying to make something as visually
just oppressive at times as this can be
and feel the shifts from being dark to
being hopeful and to have that not be
jarring it's really impressive but okay
in case you haven't watched this movie
let me talk a little bit about the story
so we're dealing primarily with mrs.
Brisby who is a mouse so we're dealing
with animal characters here which is
typical of Don Bluth his most popular
films have dealt with animal characters
you know this all dogs go to heaven
arguably Land Before Time americantale
etc etcetera etc so we're dealing with
mice and mrs. Brisby is a widow she has
three children the youngest of whom is
quite ill and her husband unfortunately
recently passed away and so she's
obviously going through a lot and she's
gotten things to try and help her
youngest get better but he's basically
got pneumonia he cannot safely be moved
but they've arrived at moving day
because they along with a you know the
resident animals in the area live in a
field and it's a field owned
a farmer and it's the time of year where
the plow comes through and normally they
just pack up they leave they wait for
the plow to do its thing then they come
back and they can't move him they can't
move this young child for fear of just a
chill in the air killing him so she goes
seeking help she goes to a number of
places seeking help she goes to what is
called the great owl which is oh man I
love the great I'll get into some of
these guys specifically but there's the
great owl who eventually points her to
the rats who live in the rosebush near
the house near the farmhouse and those
are the rats of NIMH and long story made
as short as I can NIMH was basically
kind of an acai untick spera mental
thing who increased the intelligence of
these rats they then escaped and they're
living here but they are way smarter
than rats are supposed to be and so she
goes to them for help to try and bear
out how to move her house safely not
just move her kid but move the entire
house which is sort of this little
lockbox kind of thing and so that's
that's your main thing and she
encounters various characters I
mentioned the great owl there was a crow
named Jeremy there's there's various
characters within the rats of NIMH
there's a there's an older mouse named
mr. ages there's all these wonderful
cast of characters and this movie is
just it's it is it is Don Bluth it is
uniquely Don Bluth I will put up this
and well honestly most of what he did
through the eighties so like this all of
us go to heaven Land Before Time first
americantale like though you look at
those together I'm like they are if you
want to know what Don Bluth is when he's
at his best those four movies there you
go
so first of all it's really rewarding
that the lead character the hero is not
only a female character but a mother
mother still
go out and go on adventures they stay
home and take care of the kids but she
is going to go out there and go through
a heck of a lot of very scary stuff to
protect her family
you don't get those especially in the
early 80s you didn't get those kinds of
stories for maternal characters because
the assumption is there's kids to be
taken care of
why isn't she I don't think you care of
the kids well because she needs to go
out to do what is necessary to save them
that's why so she is she's great and she
is not written as some sort of
unstoppably she's constantly terrified
but she powers through just by the the
strength of her convictions and the need
to save her children and it's really
well done it's really well portrayed and
the balance of her her passion for what
she's doing but also being scared of
what she has to confront is is handled
really well start-to-finish throughout
the film
um I mentioned the great owl and I'm
also gonna mention another character and
who I like for a similar reason but I'll
get to him in a second so the great owl
what I love about him is he is monstrous
he is big and he is creepy and he's got
these huge glowing eyes got this
intimidating voice and he's a actively
one of the good guys he's not
necessarily a good thing like a lot of
people a lot of the the animals and
characters are terrified of and me get
the implication that he kills a lot of
folks but for the purposes of this story
he is a help he's not a hindrance and I
always love when something is visually
coded as monster as villain has problem
but is helpful and relatedly to that the
rat the leader of the rats Nicodemus
I used to have a pet rat when I got my
my first apartment know what it wasn't
my first server is my second apartment
this was in Boston I got a rat and his
name was Nicodemus
and he was awesome I loved that rat Adam
trained to I used to have used to hang
out on my shoulder was only like what I
used to love to do Halloween would come
around so I'd go out like I'm you know
very basic kind of looks but I'd have
him on myself people think oh it's a
stuffed rat
then he moved like from one shoulder
over to the other people were freaked
out it was great oh he was awesome but
Nicodemus is another in the film is
another example of that sort of visually
coded as villain he is decrepid and
creepy and again no pupils he's glowing
eyes but he's he's not only helpful for
the terms of so he's benevolent
he's kind he's sweet he's caring I love
that I love that contrast if I was
younger I couldn't articulate what it
was I loved about that but now I can
more or less because I'm an adult and I
just I love the contrast that
juxtaposition between looking by all
rights like the villain of the piece
like an evil wizard kind of thing but
being a good guy that's awesome I love
it
and the the way things build and the the
triumph of of how it concludes all just
works really really well for me it's not
a perfect film there are a couple of
things that I think are more issues for
me watching it now as an adult because
take for instance the character of
Jeremy the crow who is voiced by Dom
DeLuise who is kind of I think Dom booth
considered him a bit of a good luck
charm he put him in almost every movie
he he directed certainly you know
through the 80s and he he's not unfunny
but he doesn't have a lot of narrative
purpose besides being funny and as a kid
I was fine with that because I did find
it funny as an adult it's not that he
it's suddenly like oh there's made me
laugh as a kid but now it's great
it's not awful it's it's kind of lowbrow
easy laughs but he doesn't really have
much of a purpose
in the story aside from being comic
relief and as an adult that does bother
me I don't have a problem with the comic
relief character I would like you to
have a reason for being there other than
that for the same reason that you know
I'm fine with the romantic interest as
long as that's not the the only reason
they exist in the story there's no
romantic interest in this by the way
which is another great thing about it
there's there's like a vague kind of
maybe attraction between mrs. Brisby and
one of the rats but you know what it's
not it doesn't even really get a proper
focus and good on them for that but that
but there's those kinds of issues
so with Jeremy the the traitorous rat
within the group Jenner he's just kind
of generic we don't really get enough
about him or his motivations or why he's
kind of doing what he's doing he's just
kind of you know he's the Grand Vizier
he's the scheming guy looking to take
over and there isn't there isn't a heck
of a lot to him he does at least serve a
plot function because he complicates
things into the climax which and they
needed an additional complication so yo
I'm like Jeremy he does actually have a
plot function but there isn't a ton to
him and it is kind of especially
disappointing considering that you know
the good guys made to look like villains
are so memorable but the actual villain
not quite so much that's at the
cat-dragon
that's a good look yeah Oh Don Bluth was
good at monsters cats hey have you seen
americantale
you know he's good at monsters cats so
that there are those sorts of the things
though it's a little niggling ah that
could have been a little bit better but
again those are usually issues for me
watching as an adult these were not
things that bugged me as a kid and they
don't bug my child
who had seen this movie and does enjoy
it it's not one of her favorites it's
not one that she asked for over and over
and over again but she has seen it she
did like it she has asked to see it at
least one more time since then and
that's usually a positive indicator cuz
my kid
my kid has no makes no bones about going
I'm not really enjoying this can we
watch something else tried to get her to
watch Star Wars she got as far as Luke's
introduction and asked if we could do
something else
but so I take her getting through
anything without complaints and being
able to say you know what some of her
favorite stuff was she like Jeremy a lot
that she was engaged and she enjoyed it
so I do think this is a movie that still
works
you do need a kid okay with at least
scary visuals and some scary moments
i-i-i don't know about anyone else's kid
with my kid as long as i can give her a
reassurance that it ends okay you know
the good guys win the bad guys lose it
has a happy ending that usually gets her
through pretty much anything and she
understands there'll be scary moments
and like oh no what's gonna happen parts
but it'll be okay in the end
so and this is it does have a happy
ending and the the few there are some
deaths and it but the ones that happen I
think are easily reconciled for most
kids so yeah I was really glad to be
able to go back and revisit this for the
purposes of this channel so thank you
patreon and yes I can be supported on
patreon and you don't have to do it at
such a high level that you get to
actually dictate what it is I'm gonna
review although if you want to by all
means go nuts there's more slots
available but in any case you can hop on
over there any little bit helps and is
appreciated
so until then Oh have you seen secretin
em what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are something down the
comments let's talk about it you can
follow me on Twitter send me an email
buy a t-shirt bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]